mercedes martinez of las vegas now
recently had a virtual one-on-one vegas
resident and former headliner nick
carter from the backstreet boys
he is joining forces with the cure for
the kids foundation
and also working on a brand new single
that's all in today's entertainment
report
mr nick carter or should i say the pink
crocodile
the masked singer what i mean some
thought it was a surprise some
were not shocked how was that whole mass
singer experience
for you it was so much fun um you know i
thought
i thought to myself this could be
something that my kids would really love
uh it's such a family-oriented show
you know it's just it's just clever and
exciting and
and to be able to compete you know there
there was a lot of incredible
uh incredibly talented uh people that i
was up against um
grammy award winners and just you know
just to be in that company
i i was just so so honored you make las
vegas your home and it's so
great to have you as such a a great
supportive local i
refer to you as our las vegas owned
personal saint nick and you do a lot of
great thank you for the community
especially cure for the kids foundation
what tell us more about that you know
there there are families who are who are
dealing with you know pediatric cancer
um and you know to be able to have a
place that they can turn to
um you know if you're a local in in las
vegas in nevada
uh you can go there at free of charge
and they'll take care of you
and your children um in the neighboring
states as well you know
so i just i just thought to myself you
know this is this is not a time about
me it's about other people and and what
they're going through right now and so
that's why i connected with them
a couple of things during quarantine
you've still been entertaining us
with you've got some solo music that is
coming out
and then also this collab with britney
uh the brittany thing was really cool i
thought that that
i thought i might have inspired uh
brittany a little bit when i did the
toxic on the masked singer and that that
was one of my best performances
maybe she was like oh i like that let's
do a song together you know
gotta work uh but you know um yeah i
have been recording new music um i have
a song called 80s movie that's going to
be dropping
this um this friday and new music friday
it's gonna be on spotify it's gonna be
on itunes
um i wanted to do a song on the heels of
the masked
singer after people hopefully were
entertained and enjoyed my voice i was
like
in my mind i'm like okay maybe if i
could find
a song that would just kind of be like
the
home alone version of of a song you know
with macaulay duncan yeah so yeah i did
and it's a great song
i think people are going to really like
it
i like him i've never seen an in-depth
interview with nick carter before